hi guys we are here today with the
Anastasia of Anastasia Beverly Hills
today she's going to be working her
magic on my brows where we talk about
trends how to shape your own at home and
just a few tips and tricks from the brow
Queen well thank you so much I want to
talk a little bit about this technique
that I developed long time ago based on
the golden ratio a technique that will
help everybody to determine their
eyebrow shape according their bone
structure in the natural level
eyebrow doesn't matter your face shape
your eyebrows begin about the middle of
inside of and also it's a corner of the
nose corner of the eyes this should be
the end of the eyebrows and tip of your
nose middle of the iris they should be
the highest part of your eyebrows you
have beautiful eyebrows really beautiful
so what do we need to do though to make
them extra perfect well I will fill them
in with little products to create a more
dramatic look so I'm going to start with
the end of the eyebrows it's better to
start from the highest part of the
eyebrow towards the end the tail always
could be darker and you go lighter with
a beginning
yes okay I will fill and brush with the
spoolie I'm doing few strokes of hair to
create a higher arch here and this is an
easy pencil to fill in very quickly the
strokes of hair I use this highlighter
underneath that will define the line
we'll use tinted brow gel to set the
color and hold the hair yeah yes Wow
which celebrities do you just think have
the best natural brow all my celebrity
clients they have the best eyebrows just
to name a few
among Clooney Victoria Beckham the
Kardashians candle cam I like to keep
candle like very straight and pretty and
and sexy I think she looks stunning and
Kim is more arched and fits her look so
I want to create the higher arch then I
take little pommade very little this is
a waterproof formula and you use this on
the cap and you almost you clean the
brush and I would be able to use strokes
of hair
[Music]
[Music]
to set the color and hold a hair I use
the two your brow gel and will
completely hold on to your eyebrow for
the rest of the day yes that's it I just
got my brows done by honest touch me up
this is so exciting thank you so much
for sharing your knowledge thank you
guys for watching if you'd like to see
more videos like this please subscribe
to Glamour's youtube channel and follow
us on all our social
[Music]